ahora tenemos una situación realmente
interesante tenemos nuestra balanza en
la cual tenemos nuestra masa misteriosa
esta vez la llame y para hacer notar que
no siempre es necesario llamarle x se
puede usar cualquier símbolo siempre y
cuando podamos darle seguimiento en el
desarrollo también tenemos más de un
kilogramo en ambos lados de la balanza y
lo primero que voy a hacer es
desarrollar todos los pasos necesarios
para encontrar el valor de la masa
misteriosa allí y me gustaría invitarte
a ver si tú eres capaz de expresar esto
de una manera que hebraica utilizando
notación matemática una expresión que
describa la situación que tenemos aquí
de este lado tengo tres masas 10 y 3 más
de un kilogramo y su masa total es igual
a este lado en donde tengo una masa iu y
7 más de un kilogramo piénsalo por unos
segundos
veamos la masa total de este lado tengo
tres masas que son tres d
y tres masas de 1 kilogramo
y de este lado tengo una más allá que lo
escribo como jay o bueno podría poner un
oye pero como es lo mismo no lo
utilizamos y tengo siete masas de 1
kilogramo a ver tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 si
efectivamente son de 7 y la balanza está
en equilibrio o sea la masa total de
ambos lados es la misma entonces podemos
escribir un símbolo igual y ya logramos
lo que queríamos tenemos una expresión
para esta situación de la vida real hay
situaciones en que la gente quiere
encontrar la masa de objetos
desconocidos por ejemplo cuando vas a
una joyería y habrá que saber resolverlo
y ya logramos construir una expresión
matemática para esto ahora la pregunta
sería cuáles serían los pasos razonables
para continuar solucionando este
problema y me gustaría darte unos
segundos para que lo pienses
algo maravilloso que tiene el álgebra es
que podemos abordar los problemas de
diferentes formas por ejemplo podríamos
pensar que tal si quitamos estos tres de
un kilogramo de ambos lados o qué tal si
quitamos una y de ambos lados no importa
el orden en el que hagamos los pasos
pues escogemos alguno de ellos pues qué
tal si empezamos quitando una y de ambos
lados de esta manera lograremos tener
nada más de un lado a las diez y
recuerda tenemos que hacerlo de los dos
lados sin nada más quitáramos una de un
lado la balanza ya no estaría en
equilibrio entonces lo vamos a hacer de
los dos lados de la balanza y vamos a
quitar una masa y haber la quitamos y lo
voy a hacer con este color morado y
ahora cómo se vería esto de manera
algebraica o sea yo quité una y del lado
izquierdo y entonces quito una y del
lado derecho
y de hecho eso es lo que hice en la
balanza quité una y no sé cuánto pesa
pero yo quité una de cada lado entonces
veamos que tenemos lo podemos ver
matemáticamente o sea si yo tenía tres y
quito uno o también lo podemos ver aquí
en el dibujo si de los tres quito uno
entonces me quedan dos diez y se aprecia
yo tenía tres quite uno y me quedan dos
y claro los demás cubos permanecen aquí
por ejemplo los amarillos ahora vamos al
otro lado entonces yo nada más tenía una
y la quité entonces ya no está de este
lado solo tengo las masas amarillas
entonces si yo allí le quitó una y ya no
hay más yes y mantengo mis siete bloques
amarillos y veamos nuestra balanza
estaba en equilibrio si yo quité la
misma masa de ambos lados el equilibrio
permanece así que estas dos cosas que
tenemos aquí serán iguales y se empieza
a ver muy similar a nuestro último vídeo
y aquí te pregunto en qué podríamos
seguir haciendo para simplificar esto
que tenemos aquí o sea poder aislar nada
más a las 10 del lado izquierdo piénsalo
unos segundos
bueno si lo que queremos es eliminar el
3 que tenemos de este lado entonces
tendríamos que quitar los tres bloques
de este lado pero también tendríamos que
quitar los del otro lado para mantener
el equilibrio y que quitamos tres de
este lado y tres de este lado o sea que
estamos restando de este lado 3 y de
este lado estamos restando 3 en el lado
izquierdo entonces sólo nos van a quedar
estas dos masas aging o sea que sólo
tenemos 2
pues 3 - 3 es cero y nos quedan como
aquí se puede ver 2 y en el lado derecho
también quitamos 3 bloques o sea que nos
quedan 4 sólo tenemos cuatro entonces
las dos más así es igual a cuatro
kilogramos y como hicimos las mismas
cosas en ambos lados de la balanza el
equilibrio se conserva y ahora cómo
resolvemos esto bueno lo más probable es
que lo puedes hacer con tu mente
si tengo dos veces algo que es igual a 4
bueno pero siguiendo con la mecánica que
hemos hecho vamos a regresar y pensarlo
como lo veníamos haciendo
si yo aquí tengo estas dos cosas que es
igual a los objetos que están del otro
lado el que tal si multiplicamos ambos
lados por un medio o lo que es lo mismo
dividir cada lado entre 2 que sería
equivalente a tomar la mitad de la masa
que está de cada lado entonces si yo
tomo la mitad de la masa que está aquí
solo me quedara una y de este otro lado
si tomo la
de la masa solo me quedarán dos bloques
de un kilogramo y que fue lo que hice
bueno si lo vemos aquí abajo sería lo
mismo pensar lo que lo multiplique por
un medio o que lo divide entre dos y
entonces del lado izquierdo me queda
sólo un ahí y del lado derecho me queda
un 2 y puedo poner el símbolo de igual
porque la balanza sigue en equilibrio o
sea tome la mitad de lo que había en
ambos lados y si estaba en equilibrio al
yo quitar la mitad de ambos lados pues
sigue en equilibrio y lo logramos
logramos resolver algo que al inicio no
se veía fácil de resolver y ahora
sabemos que la masa misteriosa ya vale 2
y podemos comprobarlo que esto es algo
fascinante del álgebra
podemos regresar al problema inicial y
ver si tiene sentido y vamos a hacerlo
vamos a comprobar si la respuesta que
obtuvimos tiene sentido en el problema
original y esta vez me gustaría que tú
lo hicieras si ya sabemos que la masa
desconocida vale 2 habrá que calcular la
masa total de cada la lav y tengo un 2
otro 2 y otros dos que me dan 6 más
estos tres que tengo aquí arriba me da 9
y del lado derecho tengo estos 7 que
están aquí más 2 que vale este 7 2 es 9
tenemos 9 kilogramos en ambos lados